[Music]
hey guys it's Johanna here I know that
majority of my viewers are teenage girls
perhaps you are interested in healthy
living or you may be concerned about
your weight so I'm going to share more
about calorie counting for teenagers
aged between 11 to 18 years old let's
start by understanding our body the
growth and development you are
experiencing on average 11 years old
is the start of puberty where you will
start to experience physical changes
including rapid growth spurts weight
gain and also psychological changes
which may make you more self-conscious
girls you may experience changes two to
three years earlier than boys so between
the age of eleven and a half to twelve
and a half years all you will gain an
average of eleven to twelve pounds a
year that is about one pound a month for
boys between 14 to 15 years old you
would get approximately 14 pounds in a
year remember this is just an average
some of you may grow quicker and some
slower and you will continue to grow
until about 18 years or for female and
about 20 years over mil during this
growth period you should be feeding your
body with the best nutrients in order to
grow to your maximum height and do not
ever go on a diet restricting your food
and calories may compromise your growth
both physically and mentally and we do
not want that so let's take a look at
how many calories you should be
consuming in a day when it comes to your
daily calorie requirement there are five
factors to take into consideration first
your gender second age but wait fourth
height and faith your physical activity
sedentary you only perform very light
physical activity moderately active
thirty minutes of exercise daily active
a minimum of 60 minutes of exercise
daily and very active you are physically
active for several hours daily and your
age you should be physically active for
at least 60 minutes every day with
either moderate or vigorous exercises so
on a scale of 1 to 10 moderate is
between 5 to 6 and vigorous is between 7
to 8 don't think about it as exercising
or working out instead it should be a
fun time or social time with your
friends so you can go jogging swimming
running hiking or play a game of
badminton volleyball basketball all turn
on the music and dance for a healthy
scene this is the formula to calculate
your daily calorie requirement for girls
take 135 point 3
- 30 point eight times your age plus the
level of physical activity times 10
times weight in kilos plus 934 times
height in meters for boys the formula
can be found in my description box below
so for instance if I'm an active sixteen
year or teenage girl at forty five kilos
and my height is one point five seven
meters my daily calorie requirement
would be 135 point three minus thirty
point eight times 16 plus one point
three one times 10 times forty five
kilos plus nine hundred and thirty-four
times one point five seven and that
gives me two thousand one hundred and
fifty three calories so that is the
amount of calories I need from my body
to get enough nutrients to grow and
maintain a healthy weight so you are
eating a lot more than adults in fact
because you are still growing you can
add additional 25 calories per day as
long as you aim to eat a well-balanced
diet eat until just satisfied and stay
active you will keep growing and
maintain a healthy weight on average you
should not consume
anything less than 1800 calories a day
if you are watching this video and you
think you might be obese then please
speak to your parents and consult your
doctor to lose weight healthy do not go
on a weight-loss journey on your own
please visit this website here with your
parents to calculate your BMI to find
out whether you are obese and here's the
formula for you to calculate your daily
calorie requirement and here's the chart
for your activity level here are five
tips to have with teen obesity and
please review these tips with your
parents before going on a weight-loss
journey first never go on a diet if
you're still growing the goal is not to
lose weight instead we want to maintain
your current weight all to slow down the
rate of your weight gain so for instance
when I was 10 years old I was only 25
kilos and when I was 11 I was 35 kilos
and I went up to 45 kilos at Travis OH
so within the space of two years I put
on 20 kilos that is about 44 pounds and
I did not gain in height at all so in
fact I was considered overweight I only
started to grow in height from the age
of 13 to 15 years old as I maintain my
weight and 45 kilos so it is not about
losing weight instead we want to slow
down the rate of your weight gain or to
maintain your current weight until your
height can catch up in some cases where
most of your growth has been achieved
especially if you are 15 and above for
female then it may be appropriate for
you to lose some weight if so your
weight loss should be slow and gradual
this then move on to my next point which
is to make smarter food choices
weight gain comes down to the food you
eat make small gradual changes in order
to see success so you can start by
stopping your soda drinks with naturally
sweet
beverages such as 100% fruit juices if
you go to a fast-food restaurant then up
for grilled chicken instead of deep
fried or breaded chicken reduce on
processed food and calorie dense food
such as french fries chicken nugget
potato chips chocolate bars cakes
pastries biscuits which are high in fat
and sugar go for healthy snacks such as
baked potato chips dried fruits low-fat
yogurt fruit sorbet vegetable dips and
more but tip never clean up your plate
parents if you are watching this you
should never tell a child to clean up
their plate a child should be encouraged
to eat until justice fight and then stop
if you are a team watching this and if
your parent tend to tell you to clean up
your plate then perhaps you want to
speak to your parent but learning to eat
until just satisfied in order for you to
maintain a healthy weight or help
yourself to small portion and if you are
still hungry then go for more this way
you will still clean up the plate
without overeating it is very important
for you to learn to listen to your body
from a young age in order to maintain a
healthy weight long term the father tip
is to increase your physical activities
if you are overweight chances are you
are not physically active and your age
you should be physically active for at
least 60 minutes every day yes studying
is important but having fun with your
friends is as important so ballasts are
studying and your playing time go on and
do an activity you enjoy it should not
feel like working out and the final tip
is to embrace the change remember that
your body is constantly changing into a
young lady and young men do not be
afraid of weight gain it is a natural
process to grow in height and fully
develop so even if you might be
overweight right now if you start
practicing healthy eating eat until just
satisfied cut down on junk and stay
active every day you would gradually
slink down as you grow this is the best
time in your life so it will stay active
embrace the change and never ever
compare yourself with your friends we
all grow at different rates and always
remember that you are beautiful inside
and out lots of love for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
[Music]
you